bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine qui débute sur téléphiles
soixante dix huit pour le 7-8 l'actu
chaque soir de la semaine 18 heures nous
faisons le tour de l'actualité locale et
voici les titres de cette édition peu
plaisir mais clayes-sous-bois les trois
communes doivent se retrouver au sein
d'une intercommunalité seulement ça
coince pour la mère que les siennes en
attendant ses deux homologues qui n'est
une conférence de presse conjointe cet
après midi coup d'envoi de la semaine du
dépistage du sida en ile de france les
tests à résultats immédiats ventre est
effectuée sur une centaine de lieux et
notamment à saint quentin en les
associations en danger c'est en tout cas
ce qu'estime un collectif citoyen qui
appelait à une semaine de mobilisation
les diminutions de subventions au coeur
des discussions notamment lors d'un café
débat à maurepas ce week end
nous y reviendrons sur ce plateau avec
un membre du collectif à l'image du jour
là voici tourné à benne sur le camp
militaire de la frileuse une compétition
de l'extrême baptisé mode des comprenez
journée de la boue et il y en avait pour
ses treize mille participants qui se
sont défiés autour des 13 km es22
obstacles proposer les plus rapides
n'ont eu besoin que d'une heure quand
boucler ce parcours c'est le groupe à
etsaut plutôt habitué au tour de france
est à l'open de golf qui est à l'origine
du rendez vous une première en france ce
qui fait beaucoup d'adeptes aux états
unis
les maires de plaisir et de villepion
réaffirmé lors d'une conférence de
presse à leur intention de constituer
une intercommunalité à trois avec la
ville des clayes-sous-bois comme la loi
les y oblige
avant le 1er janvier 2014 une conférence
de presse qui s'est tenue tout juste une
semaine après celle de véronique côté
millard la première magistrate des clés
qui elles remettent en cause ce mariage
catherine château patrick jacques de
dixmude un mariage à deux ce n'est
parfois pas simple alors à trois quand
il s'agit d'intercommunalité les choses
peuvent se corser il y a une semaine
véronique côté millard la merde etc et
sous-bois disait non à
l'intercommunalité entre sa commune et
celle de plaisir et de villepreux au
motif que cela va coûter cher à mettre
en place et qu'elle est trop petit en
nombre d'habitants
ce lundi les deux mère joséphine
berger et stéphane mirambeau
tenait une conférence de presse commune
pour réaffirmer la nécessité de cette
union vraiment aller dans ce sens de la
mutualisation pas du tout de la débauche
financière bientôt contraire plutôt de
l'économie et puis d'une rationalisation
et d'un apport même supplémentaires par
rapport aux attentes des plaisirs rats
ça me paraît fondamental cette démarche
je pense que cette interco à nous
permettre de faire des choses qu'on
n'aurait peut-être pas pu faire tout ça
aide quand on voit les trois villes moi
je parlais de villepreux ne les
clayes-sous-bois on a tellement de
choses en commun que c'est une évidence
on a même pu avoir si on est dans l'une
des villes où l'autre on a dit c'est
comme un gars commune nous avons les
pompiers donc ça tout ça tout son sens
être ensemble
véronique côté millard souhaite saisir
un avocat pour faire invalider la
décision préfectorale
les maires tendent la main à leurs
voisines
je crois qu'il faut se préparer et avant
de rentrer dans une opération de grande
envergure il vaut mieux se préparer sur
une quelque chose d'intermédiaire
donc j'essaye de lui pas de lui faire
comprendre parce qu'elle ne comprend
très très bien mais j'essaie de la
convaincre et avec monsieur mirambeau on
est vraiment dans cette dynamique la
machine jupe presque convaincu qu'elle
viendra en tout cas assister aux
réunions
la priorité c'est les statuts donc il va
y avoir des
réunion pour savoir dans cette
intercommunalité les compétences qu'on
transfère et il faut absolument
c'est dans ce cadre là que la mère des
crises au boss avec nous sinon nous
pouvons décider aujourd'hui et si c'est
cela à deux mais ça n'a pas de sens les
trois communes doivent donc présenté
leur projet d'ici la fin de l'année deux
à trois réunions sont déjà programmées
et cette information concernant à les
agglomérations justement 40 d'entre
elles dont saint quentin en yvelines
sont maintenant éligibles aux emplois
france et les emplois qui institue une
prime de 5000 euros pour les entreprises
recrutant des moins de 30 ans en cdi à
temps plein résidant dans des quartiers
dits prioritaires un investissement de
25 millions d'euros pour l'état afin
d'endiguer le chômage des jeunes deux
fois et demie plus élevé que la moyenne
nationale dans les quartiers populaires
les dépister rapidement le vih lancement
aujourd'hui d'une semaine dédiée à ces
flashs test à l'initiative de l'agencé
régionale de santé de sidaction et de la
région ile de france plusieurs lieux
vont accueillir les associations
partenaires dont le centre commercial de
saint quentin en yvelines
hf prévention qui intervient reçoit en
général entre 100 et 150 personnes sur
son stand le reportage de yolaine thorez
et de jonathan vilma bonjour on propose
un test de dépistage rapide ces anonymes
c'est gratuit et la réponse est
immédiate
ça vous intéresse une piqûre sur le
doigt et la réponse est donnée
immédiatement
l'association hf prévention va
directement chercher les gens pour leur
proposer un test de dépistage
donc on sait le test de trois gouttes de
sang sont prélevées puis mélangée à des
réactifs une minute après la personne
s'est tout de suite si elle est
séropositive ou non
comme j'avais déjà fait mon taf ya six
mois je suis pas d'appréhension je vais
faire mais tu as quand même pour savoir
si depuis un peu de changements moi je
passais ici par radar je savais pas
qu'ils étaient ça me permet de faire un
test plus régulièrement parce que des
fois j'y pense mais j'ai pas le temps
alors que là ça prend une minute
synthèse qui est extrêmement rapide
avant cela passage obligé avec les
animateurs de l'association
il rappelle quelques règles de
prévention et de réduction des risques
dans un centre de dépistage classique
deux personnes sur 1000 ont été
dépistées séropositives depuis le début
de l'année dans le département
hf prévention en se déplaçant sur les
universités les choeurs de citer ou les
centres commerciaux comme ici on a des
pistes et en moyenne presque dix fois
plus on se rend bien compte que le
centre de dépistage anonyme et gratuit
c'est quand il ya une prise de risque
que les gens ils vont ils n'y vont pas
forcément spontanément or aujourd'hui
entre 50 et 60 mille personnes qui sont
séropositifs mais qu'ils ne connaissent
pas leur statut sérologique
dans le cadre de la semaine flash test
l'association continue son périple
jusqu'à dimanche ce mardi elle sera à
l'étang du cora à saint-germain-en-laye
jusqu'à 21h merci beaucoup mais je vous
en fais ça par plaisir et n'hésitez pas
à tourner le mois à tous vos amis et
tout ça l'accord durera de passer merci
beaucoup merci bonne journée et nous
reviendrons sur ces tests minutes c'est
flash tester l'opération d'achève
prévention demain avec cette association
qui sera présente sur ce plateau dès 18
heures elle dans la prochaine édition du
7 8 l'aktu depuis vendredi un nouvel
espace détente snows l'aisne a ouvert
ses portes au domaine est dû mais renter
à magny les hameaux à l'aide d'une
psychomotricienne les pensionnaires du
centre sont relaxés dans un cadre
apaisant nous en avons d'ailleurs déjà
parlé au cours de nos précédentes
éditions le but c'est aider au quotidien
contre le stress de la maladie le
reportage d'olivier maniscalco et de
jonathan vilma inauguration vendredi
dernier de l'espace snoezelen au domaine
de mes rentes et à magny les hameaux
cette salle de relaxation et de
bien-être propose un accompagnement
complémentaire aux personnes souffrant
de la maladie d'alzheimer ou d'autres
handicaps mentaux l'idée de faire appel
aux cinq sens du corps humain afin de
calmer l'anxiété et le stress que peut
engendrer la maladie colonne à bulles
fibre optique musique douce ou dit
plusieurs duels essentiel vont permettre
de créer une ambiance agréable et
inciter entre les passions je pense que
ça peut apporter beaucoup avait personne
comme les personnes âgées atteintes
d'alzheimer qui sont parfois désorientés
hong kong
voilà qui sont un peu perdus ça fait
c'est vraiment les aider à 73 je pense
que c'est une bonne chose
c'est d'une part un espace où un espace
et un temps où les personnes peuvent
vraiment se poser et ressentir des
choses qui ne leur sont pas forcément
des odeurs qui peuvent leur rappeler des
souvenirs
après sarah pas un effet magique sur
cette maladie
à l'initiative du groupement
médico-social gérondi cap de saint
quentin et avec l'aide financière du
yacht club de montigny la méthode
snoezelen d'origine hollandaise
n'offrent donc pas de remède miracle à
la maladie elle propose néanmoins
plusieurs fois par semaine un havre de
paix aux patients pour alléger leur
quotidien des restrictions budgétaires
pour l'état et les collectivités ce sont
les associations qui s'inquiète sans
soutien des pouvoirs publics et avec des
chutes de subventions annoncé un nombre
d'entre elles s'apprêteraient tout
simplement à fermer un collectif
d'associations citoyennes a vu le jour
une pétition circule actuellement est
une semaine de sensibilisation vient de
se dérouler à travers la france
notamment à maurepas alors d'un café
débat nous étions présents les images
sont d'elodie moines quelle place pour
les associations un enjeu de société est
d'ores et déjà une réalité très concrète
puisque nombre d'entre elles voient leur
avenir s'assombrir victimes de
budgétaire de l'état et des
collectivités
tout au long de la semaine une
mobilisation nationale est organisée par
le collectif des associations citoyennes
et ce samedi matin à maurepas un café
débat étaient ainsi proposés invité de
ce rendez vous ouvert à la population le
conseiller général sous
smile âme au niveau du conseil général
je me suis battu avec les services on
s'est entendu avec le président et je le
dois dire qu'en tout cas sur le comptant
de maurepas sur les associations qui
m'ont sollicité
nous avons pu maintenir le financement
et pour certaines qui était en
difficulté à très court terme de
préservation de leurs activités on a pu
maintenir l'activité
une pétition a été lancée le collectif
entend aussi obtenir des engagements
fermes de la part des politiques pour
les municipales ce qu'on aimerait bien
c'est que les mères qui vont venir aux
commandes en mars prochain soutiennent
l'initiative des associations plutôt que
mettre en concurrence et associations
pour mettre en oeuvre une prestation ça
c'est bien pour le milieu économique
pour ça s'appelle des marchés publics
pour les fous tant celui d'autres rendez
vous de ce type sont prévues à l ont
cours dans le courant du mois d'octobre
et jean l'ambré membres de ce collectif
vous venez de le voir dans le reportage
est avec mon plateau ce soir bonsoir à
vous membres du collectif des
associations citoyennes on vient de voir
le déroulement d'une des réunions qui
s'est tenu ce week end une première
question est ce que c'est un mouvement
politique
ce collectif de citoyen apolitique oui
mais au sens noble faire ça n'est
absolument pas même admis leur politique
non il ya il n'ya pas de parti politique
à l'intérieur de ce collectif ni à des
militants engagés dans l'action
collective dans l'action publique
alors stop c'est qu'il ya de la valeur
derrière mais il n'y a pas de vision
partisane des choses dont on a vu que le
conseiller général étaient invités ce
mail à vannes
oui aux couleurs socialistes tout a même
fait partie d'un groupe ensemble pour
elles en cours et qu'on peut cataloguer
dans quelles tendances symbole collectif
de citoyens oui c'est ça où nous
agissons pour la participation des
citoyens aux avis qui sont données nous
aimerions que les élus écouter un peu
plus les citoyens quand elles prennent
les décisions
donc c'est par un collectif de gauche il
ya des valeurs quand même qu'ils sont
des
voilà c'est ça après on voit aussi moi
je ne suis pas encarté mais parmi les
adhérents des gens qui sont eux mêmes
engagés dans des partis politiques et ce
qui est intéressant c'est de construire
les choses collectif d'associations
citoyennes quelles sont les associations
justement qui composent ce collectif qui
est qui est national
le collectif est national et on est
vraiment très nombreux il y avait une
soixantaine de personnes qui se sont
regroupées au moment de la circulaire
fillon
peut-être vous connaissez pas les
circulaires de l'état en tout cas cette
circulaire donné la bonne marche à
suivre pour les services de l'état dans
la reconnaissance des associations et
cette circulaire assimilé toutes les
tous les acteurs associatifs à un acteur
économique comme les autres et donc par
là il fallait les mettre en concurrence
ça rappelle à leur service s'il fallait
comparer ce que proposait chacune des
associations comme un appel d'offres
tout à fait c'est exactement la logique
des marchés publics ce qu'on peut tout à
fait comprendre parce qu'il ya des
réglementations qui fait qu' il est
intéressant de pouvoir comparer les
choses mais par contre ça rend la
difficulté pour les associations qui
prennent des initiatives parce
qu'elle-même définissent leurs propres
projets et donc là elles ne peuvent pas
répondre à un appel d'offres elles sont
volontaires elle met en avant
des actions qui sont très intéressantes
parce que justement elles sont les seuls
à le faire et la mise en concurrence
mais a fait disparaître toutes ces
associations que nous qualifions de
citoyenne ces associations on peut en
citer peut-être quelques unes oui bien
sûr il ya l'association des régies de
quartier il ya des mouvements
d'éducation populaire comme peuple et
culture
il ya une association ou à laquelle je
participe qui s'appelle récit le réseau
des écoles de citoyens parce que c'est
vraiment la dimension participative qui
est mise en avant de façon à ce que les
les citoyens ne consomme pas la
république mais qu'il participe à
l'élaboration des décisions collectives
participatif c'est le mot clé un de ces
associations glisser un mot je ris
d'utiliser plusieurs fois c'est soir
quelles sont les réalités de ces
associations puisque je disais tout à
l'heure en titre vous craignez
globalement des fermetures de ces
associations oui aussi bien les réalités
aujourd'hui elles sont sur le fil
oui c'est une crainte qui est fondée on
a des témoignages clair une baisse des
subventions et parallèlement une hausse
des marchés publics
c'est pour ça qu'il est intéressant de
mettre les deux ans regard en fait les
logiques administratives sont prégnantes
ou plutôt de développer les initiatives
on développe des des piles de papiers à
remplir et les les bénévoles ne s'y
retrouvent pas alors bien sûr il
s'appuie sur des professionnels et c'est
important que les associations sache
aussi se professionnaliser mais il
n'empêche que petit à petit les
associations qui rentre dans la logique
administrative dans les logiques de mise
en concurrence
perdre leur âme et les bénévoles s'en
vont alors il ya aussi la disparition de
l'engagement bénévole qui nous inquiète
mais cette diminution des associations
est aussi justifié du point de vue des
pouvoirs publics par des nécessités
d'économies oui vous les ont creusés
aussi s'est résolu les plans de rigueur
et je partage la préoccupation de tous
que d'être le le plus économique dans
notre façon d'agir
mais justement il ya un problème des
associations quand elle touche un euro
de subvention
elle développe à côté des actions elle
s'autofinance au moins pour un euro donc
quand vous faites disparaître
dix mille euros de subventions il ya
vingt mille euros d'actions qui
disparaissent derrière donc il ya aussi
une vision économique que nous
partageons le service rendu par les
associations citoyennes est vraiment
particulier s'il disparaît alors il ya
vraiment des pans entiers de services
qui vont disparaître
alors comment on fait des économies dans
ce schéma quelles sont vos solutions
quels sont vos projets liés à l'eau je
crois qu'il faut pas se passer d'eau
qu'une idée toutes les idées sont bonnes
et justement il faut développer
l'initiative ne faut pas atténué les
solutions il faut développer des
solutions et là je crois que les
associations à côté des entreprises à
côté des services publics ont leur part
apprendre et celles qui le prennent il
faut les soutenir en toutes ces
associations que vous avez cités sont
bien sûr concerné elles sont sur le fil
vous nous le dites est ce que c'est
différent selon les régions aussi ce cas
les régions ring où les collectivités
territoriales maintiennent des
subventions est derrière tout ça par
exemple la situation sur le département
des yvelines sur la région une offre il
ya une grande variété en france la
plupart du temps en tout cas l'état elle
lui reconnaît les grosses associations
nationales d'ailleurs elle donne des
subventions à quelques grosses quelques
gros réseau très important qui rendent
un service très intéressant mais c'est
pour ça que tout sa réglementation est
développé sur son expérience à elle avec
la décentralisation
l'administration n'a pas suivi ça donc
il ya des associations pas suffisamment
des charges avec les médias il
n'arrêtera pas pris conscience pris
conscience qu'il y avait énormément
enfin 80% des associations en fait non
pas du tout salarié est sale état ne
peut pas en avoir conscience parce que
ça n'est pas sa réalité à lui par contre
les élus locaux eux ont bien pris
conscience qu'il ya beaucoup
d'associations qui rendent beaucoup de
services et qui n'ont pas de personnel
et non celle attendue sur cette question
là où les élus locaux ont des cours
répondent bien ils se rendent bien
compte de l'importance que de favoriser
le bénévolat parce que là pour le coup
c'est économique plutôt que de demander
à des professionnels il ya une
complémentarité à trouver des actions
nouvelles en général tout ce qui est
innovation il n'ya pas toujours les
métiers qui permettent de le déterminer
une pétition qui est en cours oui le
collectif citoyen s'il était reçu à
matignon c'était le 10 juillet dernier
qu'elle voulait que vous avez trouvé
auprès de matignon
ben on ait eu des échos très positifs
que ce soit
par le cabinet de la ministre la
jeunesse et des sports et de la vie
associative ou bien par le premier
ministre ils comprennent bien qu'il ya
un décalage entre les exigences
administratives des exigences juridiques
et la réalité des associations
citoyennes
donc là ce niveau là est un ensemble de
progrès qui vont être faite très
rapidement et on est très content
d'avoir été entendu quelles sont les
avancées alors par exemple très
concrètement il y avait une charte qui
définissait les bonnes relations le un
code de bonne conduite entre l'état et
des associations et bien l'avenir cette
charte deviendra un code de bonne
conduite entre l'état les collectivités
locales et des associations c'est une
très bonne chose parce que la mise à
disposition de locaux d'un ordinateur
d'une photocopieuse sont des choses très
concrètes qui peuvent tout à fait se
soutenir beaucoup d'associations les
choses avancent pour autant vous en
demander un petit peu plus encore
quelles sont vos attentes bien là il ya
depuis trois ans on observe vraiment une
montée des marchés publics et une baisse
de subvention en espère inverser la
tendance avant avec la loi sur
l'économie sociale et solidaire
il est possible que le statut de la
subvention soient mieux définies et que
pour le coup ça sécurise un petit peu
les élus qui veulent soutenir des
associations locales qui n'entre pas du
tout dans le coup dans le jeu de la
concurrence et pour lesquels les règles
de le des marchés publics s'applique
très mal donc ça ce sera pour nous
vraiment un progrès et vous allez faire
poids pendant ces élections municipales
alors faire entendre parce qu'en général
c'est le moment autrement que ça fait du
bien mais on a des idées qui semblent
bonnes puisqu'on a de bons échos avec
des élus de tous bords donc on va
essayer de favoriser le fait que les
élus locaux présentent un programme qui
prenne en compte la spécificité des
associations de façon à pouvoir les
soutenir très simplement et régler une
prise d'engagements concrets justement
au cas de victoire parce que c'était une
promesse de campagne
oui mais ça on connaît cette situation
particulière non mais il ya des choses
concrètes les élus les futurs élus
veulent l'intérêt général ils ont bien
compris que l'association développer la
conscience de l'intérêt général
vous savez les statuts de c'est assez
simple il faut être deux et il faut
avoir un objet commun alors pour avoir
un objet commun il faut commencer par
discuter de ses intérêts individuels et
commun et là c'est le début de la
citoyenneté
donc je suis tout à fait serein pour le
fait que les élus petit à petit
comprennent mieux la place que les
associations peuvent jouer et qui n'ait
pas peur non plus le bureau le
contre-pouvoir que les élus associatifs
peuvent avoir sapé c'est très
intéressant de l'altérité des points de
vue de façon à pouvoir arriver justement
est-ce qu'il saisit cette opportunité de
s'impliquer dans des associations pour
faire de la politique autrement
oui tout à fait et il ya beaucoup d'élus
qui sont issus du monde associatif vous
le savez je crois que c'est une
excellente école et en parlant des cols
justement je pense que il est possible
d'améliorer l'éducation qu'on propose
aux enfants pour qu eux-mêmes prennent
des initiatives
l'école française est brillante pour la
transmission des savoirs mais pour
apprendre à agir avec l'autre pour
apprendre à entreprendre dans le cas de
la société
elle n'a pas encore donné toutes ses
qualités
prochaine étape pour conclure c'est
qu'une réunion vous allez organiser sur
l encours ce sera le 2 octobre c'est ça
samedi 12 octobre à cette fois cyril en
cours au 7 mars dont café-restaurant
l'antarès et nous on va débattre de la
débattre pardon de la dynamique du
quartier
on est content de voir que des jeunes
vont habiter bientôt dans les logements
et les micro locale
voilà c'est ça et ça commence il n'y a
pas d'espacé du global au local là pour
ce quartier on va aller à la rencontre
des habitants ont valeur racontez-nous
notre façon de voir les choses
on va en discuter et puis chacun se
forgera un avis pour les municipales on
verra quand les candidats seront connus
et on verra leur programme dans quelle
mesure ils ont repris nos idées merci à
vous d'être venu ce soir nous parlait
donc de ce collectif d'associations
citoyennes je rappelle cette pétition et
ce rendez-vous au niveau local sur elle
en cour le 12 octobre prochain merci à
vous monsieur ismaïl à vannes vous
l'avez reçu lors de votre café débat ce
week end vous l'avez entendu d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure dans le reportage et
puisqu'il était présent à ce café débat
nous avons souhaité revenus nous avions
souhaité revenir avec lui sur cette
question de l'investiture du ps qu'il
sollicite pour les prochaines
municipales lui avons demandé ce qu'il
pensait aussi d'une éventuelle
candidature du maire sortant georges
mougeot un ancien socialiste écoutez sa
réponse
il souhaite se représenter ou doit se
représenter
c'est sa décision personnelle en son âme
et conscience
et en fonction des aspirations je n'ai
pas de commentaire à faire sur ce sujet
là c'est une décision qui lui appartient
et quelle que soit la décision qu'il
prendra je la respecterai et de toute
façon il a déjà donné un échéancier
il a dit qu'il ce qu'il donnera sa
décision d'ici la fin de l'année donc
attendons attendons donc le grand prix
international d'échecs de paris c'est
parti en revanche le rendez vous se
déroule à l encours à la commanderie des
templiers en ce moment et jusqu'au 5
octobre douze des meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux sont présents dont les numéros
deux et trois français elle 120000 euros
sont à remporter le public peut assister
au duel qui débute chaque jour à partir
de 15 heures les épreuves sont aussi
proposés en ligne sur le site de la
fédération internationale d'échecs
on écoute le président de cette
fédération il était à l encours lors du
lancement de la compétition ce week end
au micro d' elodie moines g p o and poor
reste on amène le gros prix est l'un des
plus importants tournois de la
fédération internationale d'échecs
le gagnant pourra participer au tournoi
désignant le prochain adversaire le
champion du monde
c'est pourquoi c'est si important pour
les joueurs présents ici de l'emporter
et ce qui en fait l'un des dix plus
grands prix du monde si l'an prochain
nous organiserons plusieurs compétitions
d'échec majeur en france et à paris
ce n'est que le commencement aujourd'hui
les seyssois nova first d'ethias en inde
tennis à présent ils s'appellent nils
200 îles et 2 140e joueur mondial il a
remporté à ce dimanche le tournoi de
tennis futures de plaisir après s'être
fait un peu peur en fin de match retour
sur une finale 100% belge avec anthony
rech elodie moines pendant près d'une
heure et demie il a semblé être perdue
sur le court plaisir wa pourtant maxime
automne connaît bien les lieux pour sa
quatrième participation au tournoi
future de plaisir le belge était tête de
série numéro 1
mais voilà de l'autre côté du filet son
compatriote niels desein de 140e joueur
mondial réalise la meilleure saison de
sa carrière
dès les premiers jeux ce colosse prend à
la gorge son adversaire s'appuyant sur
une excellente première balle
jusqu'à 6 4 5 1 de seine y réalise le
match parfait mais au moment de conclure
cela faillit se finir en mauvaise
histoire belge
legrand ning se met à jouer petit bras
maxime authom revient à 5 4 mais la tête
de série numéro 2 du tournoi se sont
finalement grâce à son service
score final 6 4 6 4 deux scènes fixes et
d'ainsi au français marc gicquel
ils donnent l'assaut troisième tournoi
future de la saison et va se rapprocher
de la 200e place mondiale
je suis très content que c'était un
objectif d'arriver en finale parce que
j'étais peut-être série numéro 2 mais
bon tout ça est toute façon tout le
monde joue bien donc c'est pas facile
non plus et ben je suis très content de
gagner parce que c'est le première fois
qu ici que je joue je joue bien avant
j'étais pas bien joué et je pense que je
fais le toi deux ou trois d'autres 2 3
fois et c'était jamais jamais bien dans
le tableau féminin l'expérimenté aurélie
vedy a dû s'arracher en trois sets pour
venir à bout de la prometteuse gaye
l'espériez 6 3 4 6 6 4
les basketteurs français champion
d'europe après leur victoire en finale
80 à 66 sur la lituanie hier soir vous
n'avez sans doute pas échappé à cette
nouvelle folie qui s'empare de
l'hexagone et ces sportifs qui multiplie
les plateaux télé certains d'entre eux
sont d'ailleurs des habitués du
territoire yvelinois boris diaw est déjà
venu par le passé à saint quentin en
yvelines il a réalisé un clip avec un
rappeur local
il est aussi venu disputer un tournoi de
golf pour son association caritative sur
le site du golf national
quant à nicolas batum que vous avez
aperçu il ya quelques instants il a
assisté en 2011 à la préparation à
trappes de l'équipe de france de basket
des moins de 20 ans félicitations donc à
eux est justement comment réagissez vous
à ce succès des tricolores
vos réponses au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude c'est génial ça représente la
france à l'étranger donc quelque part
c'est le prestige du pays où j'étais
très très vraiment très contente pour
eux parce qu'ils attendaient ça depuis
très longtemps est finalement ils ont
gagné persévérance voilà comme quoi dans
la vie il faut toujours persévérer
je pense qu'une magnifique victoire les
baskets dans français était très très
dynamique très ils en voulaient beaucoup
et puis ça nous c'est un spectacle
intéressant
moi je pensais que c'était comment dire
aussi un sport que j'aime bien qui va ça
va vite
où les juges en général sont honnêtes et
puis j'ai trouvé l'équipe de france au
moins ont marqué face à eux il n'avait
pas d comment dirais-je des joueurs
facile d'où on dirait il ya un verre
célèbre de de corneille à vaincre sans
péril on triomphe sans gloire
donc là vraiment il y avait à bien des
périls ils ont vaincu sait très bien
d'où la gloire fait sera fait plaisir
maintenant ce que ça m'inspire rennes
particulier mais ça fait plaisir surtout
pour les joueurs que ça fait un petit
moment qu'ils couraient après une belle
victoire effectivement fin de cette
édition du journal le 7-8 lecture vient
demain mardi 18h en direct replay sur
notre site internet
excellente soirée si vous êtes amateur
de sports de basket ce plus
particulièrement au rendez-vous aussi
tout au long de la soirée de ce lundi
avec anthony rech et son 7,8 ce sport je
vous dis donc à demain excellente soirée
où